spera tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
video sono parigi oggi siamo su un video
un po particolare volevo farlo da un
pochettino perché diciamo che quando ero
piccolo ricordo che rimasi molto
scandalizzato dal fatto che molti
cartoni animati contenevano messaggi
subliminali quindi ha detto face una
reaction ai messaggi subliminali
contenuti nei cartoni animati da pieno
di ste robe su youtube pieno tempo fa
avevo vista una roba del genere da un po
che non la vedevo e voglio vedere se
riesco a sfruttarlo io prima di prima
che me lo dica lui sai che non ho
assolutamente idea
fammi vedere la realtà amico mio
mostrami ma se con ma io non però c'è da
come ti è venuto in mente genera
veramente senso anche l'uso del cavallo
allora a forma di pene ma dai quel primo
era un po così però va bene o del re
leone addirittura
noi abbiamo vestite paranoici come la
c'è se avete la paranoia nell'anima ma
vedete la scritta stesso ovunque vabbè
next one ha comunque negato che
effettivamente quando si tratta solo
delle scritte nascoste nei mercati
animati ma anche di falli ma non credo
effettivamente quello sia un pene anche
se sembra sicuro questa musica di
sottofondo emetterà malico l'incredibile
voglio tagliarmi le vene c'è mio dio
[Musica]
cioè yo yo no fermi fermi fair però è
vero sembra adesso me lo fai inutile
sembra veramente
caspita non ci ha fatto caso
effettivamente ora che me lo fanno
notare sembrerebbe davvero questo
potrebbe essere l'unico vero sì vabbè
dai barman per palladino all'inizio
della storia a dino alla fine della
storia
potremmo stare capezzolo qual era il
problema non capisco è solo un capezzolo
non capisco quale sia il problema
arrivo cercherà un po più nel profondo
vediamo cosa si trova sul web ma basta
questa scritta se ex japan steel avete
comunque fa scritta o questo geniale in
una puntata di paperino della scritta
dietro paperone già scritto ask about
illuminati che vuol dire chiedi degli
illuminati ma gli dexter
[Musica]
chiaramente la riottosità un palo
dall'ano va bene ma basta basta vedere
la scritta sexo ovunque basta da
thriller au pays
ma perché tutti devono usare questo
effetto sonoro sottofondo che mi mette
un ansia che non ce n'è bisogno è pieno
i tre porcellini attaccato il quadro del
padre in casa loro e della nostra città
era cosa stupida però allo stesso tempo
e geniale secondo me
agosta scritta sesso però almeno ha
tolto la musica di sottofondo creepy e
ci sto tizio che urla come un ossesso lo
stesso den da bar o se cesc già parola
sesso anche questo e subliminale c'è
anche il nostro secolo
fammi vedere un uomo bello se
simpaticissimo ma che veramente ma in
europa atroci maledizione fake speriamo
che sia fei basta basta qualsiasi cosa
la puoi trasformare in sesso se vuoi
anche sulla mia ma non ci sarà qualcosa
che ti possesso anche su silente la cosa
comunque ragazzi dopo tutte queste cose
che mi hanno messo l'angoscia
incredibile addosso c'è un'altra roba
che volevo farvi vedere mi fa ridere che
per far vedere questa che stai usando un
software del 1800 mandiamola rovescio hi
fun to look marijuana c'è veramente in
confronti subliminali miei di heather in
italia far ridere ho ascoltato haters in
italia al contrario
ahia ahia uguale dolore io chiedo signor
nocchiero mas comunque ragazzi siccome
diciamo che guardare queste cose mi
mette angoscia cerchiamo qualche cosa
per farci ritornare il sorriso nel
vecchio crash medico c'era questa scena
qui no
[Musica]
il web ha preso questa cosa e la messa
ovunque questa è forse il mese più bello
che abbia mai visto vi supplico dobbiamo
vederlo troppo insieme sono ccg l'uomo
di st
di oggi la missione farete il tocco
quanto fatto bene quanto è jamie e nora
cava bene cioè ragazzi veramente fatto
da dio è la cosa più bella che abbia mai
visto su youtube degli ultimi anni ve lo
giuro cioè bello che lascia è una delle
scene più
[Musica]
è una delle scene più drammatiche degli
anime ma vista così non può far scattare
veramente fantastica comunque parlando
sempre di subliminali tranne le scritte
sex forse alcuni avevano senso di
esistere altri senso che li approva nel
senso che ci stavano alle scritte sexy
secondo me sono a caso ai ragazzi spero
che vi sia piaciuto concludo qua c'è
troppa roba in stupido messo di tutto
qualsiasi cosa prova però che mi sia
piaciuto ragazzi cosa semplice per
momento mi piace anche adesso si è
convenuto descrizione e ricordatevi che
sua mamma ma aspetta casa
[Musica]